several Palestinians have been killed in
overnight raids by Israeli forces in the
occupied West Bank we're going to go
straight to Charles Stratford who's
joining us live from romala talk us
through what's happening with these
raids
Charles yeah a number of overnight raids
by the Israeli military into various
locations across the occupied West Bank
the focus though of those raids seems to
be in around the city of Janine in the
north of the occupied West Bank we've
been speaking to uh Hospital uh sources
they now are confirming that at least
four people were killed in those raids
in and around janin um including a
13-year-old boy we started seeing
pictures I suppose around 2: in the
morning local time videos were started
to appear on social media of Israeli
military vehicles going into the city
including armored personnel carriers and
um armored personnel carriers sorry that
would be an exaggeration armored V
Vehicles let's say um and um these
military grade um bulldozers that the
Israeli military use so often to destroy
homes and and private property um the
main focus of that raid was on the
refugee camp in Janine but there was
another incident um in the village of
Burkin which is just outside of janin
there were a number of arrests made
there we've just heard in the last hour
or so another incident in the town of
cilia which is south of Janine still in
the north of the occupied West Bank um
Hospital sources there saying that the
uh there's one person that was killed in
clashes there also now that figure five
now takes us up to over a 100 deaths
since these raids started on around
October the 7th obviously on the back of
that hammer raid the attacks inside
Israel so yeah more than 100 killed um
at least
1,300 arrests made and you can only
imagine last night a terrifying
experience for thousands upon thousands
of civilians that are living in these
areas across the occupied West Bank
Charles thanks very much Charles traford
talking to us from
romala